[Music]
we're here to connect love time death
now these three things connect every
single human being on earth we long for
love we wish we had more time we fear
death
did you lose a child Howard Howard is a
brilliant creative charismatic guy used
to love life right now he hates it I
tried to talk to him I tried to reach
him and he's not there I miss him
he writes letters who are they - Howard
doesn't write letters to people he
writes to things time love death kids
write letters a Santa Claus it doesn't
mean a crazy no this is therapeutic
who did you write the letter to I wrote
a letter to death nice to meet you
they're charmed I'm sure
no people write letters to the universe
all the time most don't get a personal
response that you are I don't want this
I'm time I'm a gift and you're wasting
it you don't think I'm crazy but I'm
having conversations I am love
don't try and live without me Howard I
saw you in her eyes when she called me
daddy and you betrayed me I'm the reason
for everything
if you can accept that then maybe you
get to live again
he's reaching out to the cosmos for
pants's
there's so much more at stake here than
you even understand
you've been given a gift
his profound connection to everything
just look for it
I promise you it's there
the collateral beauty don't worry he's
not allowed to touch you he knows what
you're here for
he listens